and holy moly guys that is insane
Apple's M2 iPad Pro is finally here
after a long year and a half of waiting
and there is a lot of disappointment
because Apple seemingly changed barely
anything including the upgrade to the M2
Chip so in this video I'm gonna go in
depth to explain and show off every
little difference with the new M2 iPad
Pro because there are a lot of people
wondering if they should just buy an M1
iPad Pro for as low as 630 dollars right
now instead of paying the full 800 price
for the new M2 iPad Pro now as far as
design there's literally only one
difference which is quite funny it's the
fact that you now get the iPad Pro text
on the back of the M2 iPad Pro compared
to the previous one that just said iPad
so there you go it now says iPad Pro and
now moving over to the front everything
is essentially identical and the one
thing that really bugs people about the
new M2 iPad Pro is that it didn't get
the landscape camera like we got in the
iPad 10 which we think is a really big
deal and a nice difference when you're
using the webcam or FaceTime so it's
really disappointing that Apple did not
add that and it's likely because of the
apple pencil 2 magnetic connector and
charger right here which basically has a
lot of hardware on the inside which
would have been in the same spot that
the camera would have been in now one
thing that is new is the new hover
feature for the apple pencil which you
don't have for the M1 iPad Pro but check
this out let's test it bam you could see
that it is hovering when you get close
which is actually pretty cool but I
don't think this is a hardware
difference because nothing changed in
terms of the display or Hardware that
would enable this to happen I'm pretty
sure they could have given it to the M1
but they probably chose not to this is
definitely cool though I'm sure it could
help some artists out there to be able
to see the color and size of your
drawing so as far as differences that
you could actually see and feel and use
that's basically it everything else is
going to be on the inside in terms of
the different performance aspects but
luckily there is something new and that
is the new snap case and Float folio
from our sponsor moft so all you do is
snap it on like this and it even has a
pass through for the SMART connector and
on the front you can see it has this
nice little pocket to protect the apple
pencil also it doesn't get lost as
easily and because of the design it
doesn't interfere with any kind of
keyboard cases and that includes moth's
new float folio which magnetically
connects over the snap case and it
covers up the front and the back so now
basically everything on the iPad Pro is
protected the sides the corners the
apple pencil everything but that is not
the main point of the float folio
because you can adjust it for four
different angles for your creativity
using the origami hybrid design and this
one is meant to give you 1.6 inches of
floating with the iPad and then we have
the final one which is the coolest you
just pull it back like this and Bam you
get over three inches of floating for a
nice media consumption setup so be sure
to check out the snap case and Float
folio using the links in the description
and pin comment below and now getting
back into the iPad Pro comparison
nothing else has changed guys we have
the same exact displays we don't have
mini LED like some leaks we're showing
us so the only thing left to test out is
the performance so let's jump right into
that starting with a storage speed test
to see if we actually got an improvement
in storage so let's run Jazz disk bench
right here and look at that we seem to
have the same score around 1600 read
megabytes per second and around 875 to
900 for the right no difference in
storage so with that said let's jump
into the actual M2 Chip performance
starting out with geekbench 5 and I do
want to mention that they both have the
same eight gigs of RAM and even though
the M2 Chip within the MacBooks can go
up to 24 gigs of RAM you actually don't
have the option in the M2 iPad Pro it
maxes out at 16 if you buy a one
terabyte of storage model or larger but
now getting into the actual CPU test we
can see that the clock speed of the
performance cores is now up to 3.49
gigahertz compared to
3.19 on the M1 and that should lead to
faster single core performance let's see
and there you go we have our scores it
looks like we have 10 faster single core
which is actually pretty decent for a
year over a year difference and 16
multi-core performance gain that's also
pretty good and honestly that kind of
surprises me because it's packing that
much performance like laptop levels of
performance and a super thin iPad Pro I
mean Apple never stops amazing you the
only issue with it though is the M1 iPad
Pro was already quite Overkill compared
to the actual apps that you can download
because you don't have those same heavy
hitter apps like you have on Mac OS that
really take advantage of all the
performance on the iPad and that's its
biggest downfall but of course we do
want to see all of the differences so I
have speedometer 2.0 which is a web
browsing Benchmark and this is basically
going to give you the actual snappiness
of browsing the web so let's see if that
improves and wow I was actually not
expecting this big of a difference look
at that 26
higher score in speedometer so you
actually are going to feel a snappiness
difference with the M2 Chip that's
actually way better than I expected so
that's a pretty decent Improvement now
let's go back to geekbench 5 and run the
Metal Graphics test and holy moly guys
that is insane 33 300 on the M2 iPad Pro
compared to
2006.99
61 faster graphics performance that is
absolutely unbelievable I can't believe
you're getting this one much performance
in an iPad Pro and no this is not
throttled compared to the MacBooks so
with that said I actually want to do a
longer term stress test this is
basically a gaming performance it has
gfx bench metal and I'm only doing the
1440p Aztec Ruins High tier off-screen
test because that's what I ran on the M2
MacBooks and that'll give us a better
idea if it is actually throttled down
compared to those and would you look at
that when it actually comes to real
world gaming performance or graphics
performance there is now only a 21 boost
to the actual graphics performance
compared to that huge 61 we saw in
geekbench metal so when it comes down to
real tasks it's not that big of a
difference and one thing that I do want
to emphasize is that I recently did a
gaming comparison with the M1 iPad Pro
versus Samsung's flagship and in that
test and basically every game I tested
the M1 was already almost at perfect
120 FPS average so in that case it was
already reaching its limits the limits
of the actual 120 hertz display itself
so with that said in terms of gaming
there's no real point to go to the M1
iPad Pro because even the best game like
genshin impact was already right there
close to 120 but you know what just for
good measure let's also Run 3D Mark's
Wildlife extreme unlimited test to see
if there's any differences with a
different gaming Benchmark now while
this is running I do want to mention
that it's a pretty heavy hitting
Graphics test and I have not noticed any
display dimming or overheating
whatsoever on this model so I don't
think there's gonna be a difference in
terms of that and there we go we have
our scores and this time the results are
a little bit better it's now 35 faster
so 40.5 FPS compared to 30.1 so it is
doing a little bit better in this test
and honestly this is actually impressive
and I think the benefit here if you were
to choose the M2 iPad Pro is if we do
get even better and more graphically
demanding games coming soon which
unfortunately I don't think we are
compared to genshin impact which is the
downside but hey at least you have the
bragging rights of more performance for
now and now one thing that Apple did
upgrade on the M2 iPad Pro is the
wireless connectivity including Wi-Fi 6E
and Bluetooth 5.3 which is going to be
more efficient maybe use less power
increase the range so that's a nice
boost as long as you also have a
Bluetooth 5.3 device that it connects to
like the new airpods Pro 2 or the new
iPhone 14 models now as far as Wi-Fi 6E
we unfortunately don't have a Wi-Fi 6E
router in this office so it's not really
going to help us as well as everybody
else that does doesn't specifically have
a Wi-Fi 6E router and our internet is
kind of slow here because we have
Comcast Business Internet which is
slower but just in case let's see if
they maybe boosted the antennas to give
faster performance and wow would you
look at that somehow the new iPad Pro
actually got worse instead of 85
download we got 65 for some reason and
instead of 16.3 upload we have 13.6 that
might be just a negligible difference or
room for error I'm not sure but it's
definitely not better so now let's move
on to video editing because yes the new
M2 iPad Pro does support prores and
coding and decoding so let's see what
kind of real world difference that
actually makes I have a five minute 4K
prores video right here so I'm gonna go
ahead and Export it just like that and
now while this is running I do want to
mention that iMovie just came out with
an an update and both of them are
updated right now so everything should
be running nicely but so far it's not
that far ahead so we have our scores in
the new M2 iPad Pro took 2 minutes and
55 seconds to export it while the M1
took three minutes and 25 so it is
faster but definitely not worth the
extra cost so now with all of that
testing done and finished let me give
you guys my thoughts on whether you
should be buying the M2 or the old M1
well to be honest because the M1 was
already so powerful and in many ways
Overkill I don't think it's worth it yes
it has a new float Magic Pencil feature
it has Wi-Fi 6E and it is faster but
honestly guys I would just go for the M1
iPad Pro that you can get for as low as
630 dollars and that is my final take so
hopefully you enjoy this video and if
you did definitely click the circle
about to subscribe and check out one of
those two videos right over there thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next video
[Music]